so were you saying you don't think body
count matters like by and large
yeah yeah so was everyone no one tells
the actual number okay everyone lies
about it cap okay okay so question will
you say your body count then since it
doesn't matter
it doesn't it doesn't matter right it's
less than five
cap
s
cap okay what about you guys what was
the question then wait why don't you
just say it it's less than five okay so
what what's the exact number four four
okay what about you guys body counts
the only reason I I say this is because
like if what if it does if it really
doesn't matter why doesn't everyone just
tell each other yeah yeah I feel like
they should be more open about why is it
capable
why are you guys saying this cat when a
woman says that is this on one hand is
that not a real thing anymore
um it was just because there's not many
virgins around me
because men always seem to put that
woman and lying about their body count I
don't understand
why why would we be lying about our body
count
wait can you say that again sorry women
lie about their body Camp because they
don't want to reveal their true nature
really yeah so for a woman's a [ __ ]
hoe she's gonna keep that literally
hidden she doesn't want nobody to know
that she's the whole the streets are
talking the streets do you think you can
tell though like like because example if
I meet a girl in a club I'm I'm more
like and they're like they seem like
that type of person but if I meet a girl
in the library who's never been to a
club before I'm gonna probably believe
her body count over someone who like
dude like you can kind of tell I'm not
saying in general but the the way girls
act if they're confident bubbly stuff
like that like you you what are you what
do you guys think because I I think
girls know more behind the scenes than
guys do like we hear more we know more
do you think guys can tell
no no no no
they think they can't tell because
they're already saying Kappa and it's
already wrong
same way they can't tell when their
girl's cheating the same way they can't
tell someone that's shame were you
speaking from experience
not my portion
was there someone you know
that that happened with what
happened in the know you're laughing
I'm just saying there's a lot of girls
out there that move mads they have men
at home
their man don't know they don't know do
you think that they're cheating because
they're married or in a relationship
with their second choice and it wasn't
who they really wanted I feel like
um when it comes to relationships people
um lose that drive when the years like
start to pile up people stop being like
as affectionate as romantic like going
that extra mile I think that's what
drives people apart and maybe that's
when one person might step out you think
women get bored
and then she I feel like if you get
bored then you haven't picked the right
person
or maybe it could be attention like like
the person someone else is giving you
more attention than your partner which
you don't know that but waiting your eye
in the first place because something is
happening yeah yeah but it's tiring like
I'm not gonna lie like even like I'm
married and happily married and
everything but like it's tiring just
like my wife puts on makeup or puts on a
dress and if I don't say anything like
anything at all then that's it a mood's
ruined right so it's like I have to
comment because they've made an effort
but to me it's like I don't care but is
it maybe because you didn't compliment
her enough when you guys were dating or
but that that's what I mean like it's
like and guys just don't express it as
much maybe they're I'm thinking it in my
head but I'm not gonna say it like it's
just like you're quick to go and like
someone like a girl's picture on
Instagram I mean I don't do that so I
can't speak for all guys
but I I don't do that because I I just
find that I find that action a bit weird
like going on Instagram looking at other
girls and then liking them or like say
if like a lot of guys these days watch a
lot of twitch streamers like the female
twitch streamers yeah and and I feel
like if you had a partner that is a lit
to me a little bit weird if you had a
partner like well it depends why you're
watching the stream of course but for me
I it just feels a little icky
well I think like women
they are very difficult to satisfy which
is why
um what was it body count you said body
count which is why that's so important
so that they can connect to their
husband
um yeah I think that's it and I also
understand your point when you were
saying how they were sleeping with guys
that are like tens and nines when
they're like not because it just like
they want that but they can't attain it
um
yeah and that's why I think like a lot
of girls think they're settling but it's
just their level your level is what you
can get to commit to you
otherwise it's out of your league I've
heard that before yeah I mean guys
levels who they can get to sleep with
them girls level is who they can get to
commit to them
if you can't get them to commit if he
doesn't want to be with you that's not
your level
and just to add on that right you said
something me yeah you said
you said ah when I'm power corrected you
said date
when we were talking about guys sleeping
with them and it was the idea that most
girls have it in their minds that the
tens that they're [ __ ] let's say if
they're a six
they're actually dating them
but in fact you're actually just
sleeping with them and so most girls
have it like oh I'm dating that guy but
really you're not
and that's the delusion that we're
trying to point out that a lot of women
who are [ __ ] the tens who are
actually sixes are not understanding
that that's not their level because they
think they're dating them but really
they're just sleeping with them yeah
because I would also say those guys at
the top level if you are high value man
or whatever you want to call it they
have more choice so like you're not the
only pretty girl going for them right so
then they actually are looking for other
things because they have a ton of pretty
girls going for them and whereas the
girl probably thinks in that situation
oh I'm a catch I got I got this guy
stuff like that but but I from my
experience the the people who who are
higher earners they if they do get a lot
of girls anyway they're actually more
picky or on who they who they want so
why do so many like ugly guys have such
a high body count if that's the case but
it's not true is it because they have
money it might be money no they're not
actually ugly that's the thing you you
think they're ugly because women find 80
of men unattractive but it's the same
move like ugly girls as well like how
how I come it's so easy for them to get
the guy that's a 10. well yeah it
depends there's a couple dynamics that I
see if the guy's a 10 like usually she
has other qualities
oh is he dating her sleeping with her no
just sleeping together oh well guys
asleep with anything
yeah guys guys will sleep with girls
they would never be seen in public with
ever yeah and you see people cheat with
uglier girls like they might have a
banging wife
you got to worry about the ugly girls
too you gotta work oh that's your baby
mama explain it no it's a man men are
looking to qualify where women are
looking to disqualify so like if you're
going on a date with a guy you're
thinking like I have these requirements
and let me see if he meets them where
men are like oh is she hot enough good
enough
is she is she nice enough oh that's
maybe not nice enough to date but
tonight that's yeah good enough because
men men swipe right on dating apps
around 50 of the time so they find
roughly 50 of women attractive where
women only find five to maybe 20 on the
high end percent of guys attractive
wow so yeah yeah and the guys you know
you said ugly guys aren't but the thing
is ugly guys just aren't getting
anything at all those are the people
you're even acknowledging the people
that you're even talking to there's a
lot of guys that are just at home all
day that they just like do whatever
they're doing that that you don't even
see so so it's in your circle of guys
that you're like oh this guy's ugly but
it's leaving people but then that's why
one in three are what what do you say
one in three are like virgins or
something like yeah but someone might
find them attractive that's because
they're ugly to someone no no you and on
top of that maybe you're right you said
that they're sitting at home that's
probably why they're not they're not
[ __ ] because no one can see them
they're not visible to the world as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible